en juillet 1858 cette célèbre fontaine
classé monument historique coule à flot
dans ce quartier de mode canal elle
devait à l'époque pallier le manque
d'eau à fort de france
depuis des lustres et ne coule plus elle
est laissée à l'abandon
aujourd'hui la fréquentation de ce lieu
a bien changé
certaines habitations sont abandonnées
elles sont 3 ti la doua qu'elle présente
comble du sort l'eau coule à flots
gratuitement dans ceux d'été phénomène
insupportable excédé par cette ambiance
nombreux du séminaire collège
un auditeur lancé ce matin un coup de
gueule si notre antenne
elle a envahi et pdk mais là les gens
sont rassemblés comme des cafards
exactement ça les cafards qui sont
rassemblés au niveau du monde des dos et
areva chargé des finances mais pas si
elle a amplifié
alors la mairie de fort-de-france la
police les gens qui sont censés
organiser la fille de la ville
s'il vous plaît la rue de la fontaine
guesdon ça ne va plus
trafic de drogue misant sonore situation
confirmée par bon nombre fouilles allait
président dans ce quartier les gens se
croient que la maison ils sont tous en
train de se battre tout en train de se
battre il suffit de revenir près de la
fontaine pour vous rendre compte
la nina journée la nuit c'est pareil
j'ai l'habitude va de 9 ans c'était pas
comme ça j'ai toujours connu monsieur
fortin mais les gens de l'extérieur qui
vient mettre du bordel là au moins mais
mieux délimiter hugues hotier séchage du
cours du bail au médaillon compter sur
mon passage que ça vous fait oublier
parce qu'il est toujours membre a la
même silhouette est sorti en même temps
un mauvais sort du court moment mais les
bulls soit c'est la vie ou sur l'amo le
trafic illicite un fléau qui touche bon
nombre de quartiers en martinique
la municipalité de fort de france
annonce un vaste projet de
réhabilitation et de rénovation de votre
journal
des discussions ont déjà eu lieu avec
les personnes qui occupent les parcelles
qui sont dans le quartier et donc nous
allons continuer par des forums avec la
population pour expliquer ce que nous
voulons faire pour nous mettre d'accord
sur le processus et ensuite ce processus
se mettre en oeuvre concrètement ça a
commencé au niveau de l'ancienne caserne
des pompiers jusqu'à quel niveau de
l'avenue de gaulle canal bella on a
jusqu'à convient puisque c'est toute
cette parcelle toute cette parcelle du
territoire qui est concernée ou l'avait
dit par la caserne des pompiers ensuite
le plateau fabre et ensuite convient
donc les choses vont se mettre en oeuvre
petit à petit les résidents de bol canal
devons encore prendre leur mal en
patience car entre le projet de
réhabilitation des procédures d'abandon
manifeste
le combat n'est pas encore gagné